[Music]
i go fishing a lot and scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast first thing get your eggs
cooked bring the water up the boil onto
the spoon
and lower them into the water that way
they don't hit the water and crack
four and a half minutes that'll keep the
center
nice and slightly runny
now
ground sausage meat i'm gonna make mine
a little bit spicier i'm gonna crumble
in black pudding
that helps to season the scotch eggs
inside a little touch of salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple
[Music]
combine that blend in the apple and the
black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shell come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center i
want that little bit of richness with
the yolk
next you need to get yourself organized
with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and breadcrumbs
take
your mince golf ball size
spread the pate manipulate with your
thumb
and then
sit your egg in there
and spread
the sausage over the egg
and you just seal that over
it's really important to keep that nice
even coating of sausage meat around the
egg you don't want it too thick
otherwise it gets too dense and it's
unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't stick
into the egg
roll it round
shake off
any excess egg wash and roll it into
your breadcrumbs you can use this same
three-stage method to breadcrumb
anything you like from chicken goujons
and fish fillets to fina schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs japanese
white breadcrumb so no crust
you can experiment by adding flavours to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
citrus zest
i always like to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once bread crumbs lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimeter deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked
soft and running the center so the
objective is just to cook the sausage
meat and the black pudding
look great don't they go and grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
round
just to get off any excess oil and then
to transport them
some greaseproof paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder i never
catch any fish
because i'm always too busy eating my
scotch eggs
[Music]
my ultimate black pudding lace scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
my ultimate picnic keeps it simple with
dishes that all work brilliantly well
together and that's one of the secrets
you have to treat a picnic like a
celebration meal make sure you've got a
stunning selection and a great balance
of tastes and textures but above all
make sure it's fun i've saved my three
most indulgent dishes for a tea time
picnic treat
a stunning prawn and cucumber salad with
a spicy yogurt dressing
a simply delicious anchovy dip
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake that
won't fail to revive a flag in family
until he's keen to get in on the action
[Music]
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic first things first we have to
slowly melt the chocolate
that's bad that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there
next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good
if we melt chocolate too quickly it
starts to separate and destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the winter though no
that's gonna be the crunchy part of our
fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it
now peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely now
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there marshmallows my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly soon
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that a little
mix with daddy please look they're all
melty nice and creamy and gooey
now we're gonna line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it mm-hmm
you just set it yeah i want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying it nice and
flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get the spatula
okay and look
how delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
i couldn't because it's not set
so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little squares
triangles triangles
push push good
but the important part pushing it down
is that we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice okay
[Music]
fridge cake's done
now i'm gonna make the most amazing
anchovy dip with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees c for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chopped garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
[Music]
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
blitz to a paste and add pepper
then decant into a jar ready to
transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chilli yogurt dressing with
a prawn salad first things first i'd
like you to make the dressing
fish sauce
doesn't really smell like fishes so one
and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chilli
i like this especially if you have it on
the side of the form
a little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good
and
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
four
zest in there
why are you making it in a jam jar not a
bowl well this is for a little picnic
and it's a great way of transporting
we squeeze the lime in there and then we
put
[Music]
it's a bit like a tummy
see
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes only sometimes thank you
for that
kind of gives you
the first time you have it's like a
little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy
but delicious
now cucumber and the salad i want to get
rid of all the seeds so if you just nice
and gently
peel
the cucumber why do you feel it can you
not eat the skin on it you can eat the
skin but i want this salad to taste
light and fresh
you can use a knife for this too though
can't you you can peel with a knife but
a speed peeler takes off the slices nice
and thinly so much quicker so much
quicker that's why it's called a speed
peeler
looks better now looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it
now you get your spoon
let's see
what happens
a teaspoon just takes out all those
seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad go all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
there you go so see where your knuckles
are there
that's what's always going to protect if
you put that little finger out
this little piggy
boom comes off what did i tell you about
daddy's knuckle that's the first place
you cut off
all the time there you go
the next addition to our prawn salad is
firm juicy baby gem lettuce
look at the lettuce in half what about
the butt
the butts
[Music]
i'm keeping the butts on for now so when
i slice it it stays together
okay
and then a little bit there
we don't use
okay
when you prepare lettuce for a picnic
you never slice it too thinly
okay otherwise it will it's good prawns
are ready
[Music]
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
and the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because i'm
going to put the prawns on here to
protect the lettuce
get your cucumber
i put my cucumber on
and then finally that is
okay
now the salad is not going to go soft
why is that because it's not that it's
not straight onto the dressing that's
right
what happens is we wrap this now and
then we get to our picnic drizzle the
sauce on top we mix it up
we've got the dressing on the bottom and
the dressing on top
of the dressing that's right
a little bit of tim film do you know the
cling film check i don't know the clint
field trick yet no thing fell over the
top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my age then well
okay
salad in the fridge with the dressing
ready to go for a picnic
this is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with crudites
and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut fridge cake
you